what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
okay so four all-new all-different
Avengers the Civil War two tie-ins are
actually kind of like one shots like 13
14 15 and even the annual are really all
just like one-shot comics um I guess
they kind of exist as trades but in
truth you can kind of read them in
isolation but number 13 and all honesty
I think it's probably the best one
because it deals largely with vision and
it deals with the idea of time paradoxes
but the kicker is this as you guys know
I haven't really done anything on
all-new all-different Avengers yet I
haven't done volume 1 and the reason for
that was just I was kind of curious to
see how civil war to play it out because
Mark Waid well he'll mark where he's
been writing comics for damn near thirty
years but the way he does things is he
tells like the opening salvo the opening
story and then he comes back and like
basically offers the backup story to it
that's usually how he does his stuff he
did it with the flash he's done it with
a multitude of different characters it's
kind of his stick and so I figured you
know we'll give a little while we'll see
what he does maybe he'll go back and
change it maybe you won't bus we have
Marvel now 2.0 coming out which
basically gets rid of all new all
different Avengers and that replaces
them with just Avengers but the idea
here is that this comic seems actually
be you know exactly what I was what I
was thinking it might be it seems to
actually be the sort of a backup feature
or I guess this this story that tells
how it is the volume one happened so
we're gonna throw this out and then
probably the next Avengers story will be
will be volume 1 properly minded to do
the other one shots for civil war ii but
i digress enough rambling um the cool
thing about this story mark wade is
nothing if not a guy that really knows
how to explore these really cool
concepts of like consequences you know I
think he's less I don't think he's
really good with like character dialogue
so much is he's cool with like telling
us a story with narration if that makes
any sense but again this this largely
focuses on on vision I wanted to keep in
mind here is that in volume 1 the
villain came to conquer had basically
shown up in the the present-day Marvel
Universe the difference here was that
where normally there's just Kang the
Conqueror just D guy from the future who
shows up makes life hell for the
superheroes for a while and then leaves
this version that came to conquer would
basically just kind of been split and
scattered among the timestream and so
the one in the modern day was a guy
named mr. Griffin who basically wanted
to establish a kingdom for himself you
know establish a dynasty for himself and
so what this did is it basically again
allowed the the Avengers to go against
the sort of you know different iteration
of Kaine the Conqueror kind of Mark Waid
to take on the character but it also
established the vision basically was
taken over by mr. Griffin along with a
guy named
we're knocks we'll get into that when we
cover vol 1 but basically he was taken
over and he was used to fight against
the Avengers the problem with this as
far as vision is concerned is that the
idea of why this can happen the emotions
that he's experienced they can be
manipulated are really more of a
downfall than anything else is so
because of that he basically purges his
emotions every once in a while now this
is not the first time misses happened
it's actually kind of cool that Mark
Twain's drawing on this he's not doing
it overtly but when it came to the
character of the vision for the longest
time I mean he was a guy he was like
data from Star Trek radda music I was
just learning his emotions he was
learning how to become more human the
cool thing about this though was that
Marvel basically came along and kind of
ret Conda Skerritt or they sort of
rebooted vision no pun intended
where they basically rebooted vision by
essentially having his memories stripped
away by having his bodies more or less
broken down rebuilt but his personality
was gone the the brain patterns of
wonder man that were used to basically
give him life were effectively taken
away and so because of that he was very
Hollow he was very emotional event that
went away and he was restored to his nor
self but with all-new all-different
marvel he had basically purged his
memories and just essentially started
over which is away from all to just kind
of cut the relationship between vision
and Scarlet Witch which in truth had
really been coming to an instance
Avengers disassembled but the fact
remains here the division is is more or
less of this mindset that he was
manipulated by Kane the conqueror and
he's really kind of taken it on himself
to defeat Kane the conqueror now this is
where the story comes into it comes into
a real kicker because King is a time
traveler I mean that's that's his main
jig I mean he's a time travel he jumps
from the future to the past and
everywhere in between in an effort to
basically take over really all of time
itself to kind of rule the entire
history of the universe from some point
in time and so what happens as vision
actually travels to Ulysses and begins
having a really cool conversation with
him now keep in mind Ulysses is kind of
like the main focal point for Civil War
too because this takes place before the
conclusion of Civil War two and so
Ulysses hasn't joined the cosmic
entities due to his ability to see all
different realities of stuff he hasn't
joined the cosmic entities yet but he is
the guy that's basically going around to
all these different characters and
saying hey I have this permission and
then those characters respond
accordingly into their own comic books
but instead of doing that directly here
Ulysses doesn't really provide vision
with a with a premonition instead vision
goes to him and says how do your powers
work how do you cope with knowing how
the future is going to turn out
and what do you do with that kind of
information and even goes as far as to
basically ask the question are you
familiar with the idea of basically
stopping people before they commit
crimes really you know this is the sort
of you know predictive justice now this
is a really really cool thing this is
why I love visions character because
vision is is so much like the Silver
Surfer in terms of his character when
Norrin Radd was first made into the
Silver Surfer he lost all semblance of
his identity over the course of the
years he began to regain it but when he
ran into humanity he came across this
race of people that were contradictory
that you know just didn't quite make any
sense well I know I can't afford that
but I'm going to buy it anyway you know
from a visions perspective from a silver
surfers perspective the question would
be well if you know you can't afford it
then why you buying it you know I mean
it's it's one of those really cool
things the vision looks at this and says
you know if you had the ability to stop
a crime before it happened would you do
it even if the person that you were
resting hadn't actually done anything
yet and the case he brings up is the
caustic example would you kill Hitler as
an infant and that raises so many great
more filler more philosophical questions
because there's a lot of people out
there well I mean imagine what happened
if you stopped for like imagine you
killed Hitler before he rose to power
you know let's say that it's at the beer
hall push and let's say you just bust in
there and you assassinate Adolf Hitler
maybe he's training as an artist in
Vienna you know before he swept into all
the anti-jewish sentiment and let's say
you killed him
well then what would happen well there's
no guarantee that the world would turn
out a better place in fact a success of
America post World War two was because
of World War two war bonds and all that
kind of sub after World War two America
entered into an onion really an
unrivaled era of economic prosperity
because of the fact that men were
fighting overseas women took up jobs in
the United States that they normally
wouldn't have been able to take up and
it assured in this full era a feminist
movement and the argument that women can
do the same jobs that men can but if
Hitler had never risen to power
that conflict never would have happened
and it may very well be the society is
nothing like it like it is now you know
the civil rights movement ever happened
so minorities have no rights women don't
and women don't have jobs I mean it
would have been a crazy situation but
there's no way to know what would have
happened there's no way to guarantee
that the outcome would be what you want
it to be and the vision recognizes this
the vision sits down and says if I go to
the birth of Kay in the Conqueror and I
basically were to kill him what would
happen because you got to keep him on I
mean just just taking came to conquer
for example let's just take the idea of
the villain apocalypse alright let's
just take the character
of Apocalypse Now when Kay the conker
went back in time his idea was to
basically go back to the point at which
apocalypse emerged and to capture him
for his own uses if Ken had never done
that King would have never ran into
these various people
Ozymandias you know apocalypse may never
have risen to power it may have been
that because of the actions of came to
conquer that over the course of
apocalypses life he ran into a celestial
ship he basically was able to use
celestial technology and the result was
that he became the villain that we all
know and love today had Cain the
Conqueror not gone back in time that may
not have happened now if that hadn't
happened then we wouldn't have had cable
and wouldn't have Nathan summers which
means you wouldn't have x-force who
wouldn't have a lot of these teams that
exists a lot of these events that it
unfolded you know during the events of
civil war for example cable showed up to
the president United States and said hey
you cannot enact the superhuman
Registration Act I know how it will turn
out if apocalypse never existed cable
never existed if cable never existed he
never told the president about that and
maybe Civil War turned out entirely
different there's a million different
things that could have happened if came
the concur simply ceased to be and it's
really cool that Mark Waid is toying
with this because there's so many
consequences so many you know so much
fallout here now with regards to visions
quest you know I guess really him going
on this journey to really try to to
basically defeat became the Conqueror at
the very least to get to the point where
he has the opportunity to make that
decision
he basically breaks into parker
industries and he ends up hijacking dr.
Doom's time platform now keep in mind
here Parker Industries is basically the
Baxter building I mean we learned about
that an amazing spider-man volume one
worldwide when he when Johnny Storm
showed up and was like why do you have a
Parker industries logo branded on the
side of the Baxter building Peter Parker
said I did that so that when the
Fantastic Four come back they don't have
to worry about somebody else having
bought their house bought their building
you know if they ever come back of Reed
Richards and Susan storm come back I
will give them miss building back it was
really just kind of holding on to it
keeping the memory alive but all the
artifacts that the Fantastic Four had
collected over the course of their
superhero careers whether they were
taken from villains or you know they
were built by Reed Richards whatever the
case may be we're all collected within
the Baxter building and one of these
included dr. Doom's time platform now of
course because of the fact that the
vision is basically going on this black
ops mission more or less is very
subversive you know he really tries to
keep hidden from everybody but when he
goes back to the early rise of of K
macabre I'm not really
as one of the earliest actions that came
to conquer when he had gone back to the
days of ancient Egypt where he would
eventually meet apocalypse vision
initially interferes with the idea of
either trying to assess the situation
figure out what's going on potentially
even kill Cain the conqueror but in the
midst of all this he's basically met by
this shadow demon now the cool thing
here is that the shadow demon I've just
basically battles him almost every step
of the way but in their conflicts they
basically arrive at the places that
vision needs to be more specifically he
basically finds that you know I just
came to conquerors Timeship the vessel
that he used to travel back to the days
of ancient Egypt now of course vision
looks at the date that you know Rama
taught where I'm sorry that they came
that concur would most likely travel to
you and it ends up being 30 22 now the
reason why this matters is because
during the story the rise of apocalypse
after apocalypse had basically come to
power and had a you know taken up really
kind of cast out came the Conqueror came
to conquer it led back to thirty 22 so
again this is Mark Waid basically tying
in to the existing history and he's not
really leaving a lot of things to
continuity errors with regards to this
story but you know the vision basically
travels back to 30 22 and and seeds came
to conquer you know ask his younger self
where he's kind of going through
learning about time travel learning
about these different things but again
you know this this shadow demon appears
out of nowhere and you know begins to
wreak havoc you know even more on the
vision now over the course of their
conflict over the course of their battle
vision comes to the realization that
every time traveler has an artifact of
some kind they have a device that they
use to basically anchor them to to their
own sanity different people use
different things where for Cain the
Conqueror he has his helmet and is how
it literally just like stores all the
information from everywhere he's ever
been everywhere that he intends to go to
you know that kind of thing so that if
he gets lost in the timestream he can
always find his way back when vision
takes this helmet while a lot of the
future actions of Cain the Conqueror
haven't been recorded yet his birth has
been recorded and so because of that he
basically travels back to the point
where paying the Conqueror is
essentially just an infant laying in a
crib now this is where Mark Waid begins
to get really cool and this really I
would say the dialogue here is kind of
special it's it's really something
interesting and this is where Mark Waid
gets kind of funny because when it comes
to characters that have you know super
you guys have like a lot of character
they've got a lot of ambitions goals
desires so on and so forth
Mark Waid kind of struggles a little bit
I would say his run of Wally West was
probably the exception to the rule in
terms of great character development but
when it comes to characters like vision
who are things
you know cold who are thinking you know
in a calculated logical way Mark Waid is
really good at that not mean to say the
mark Wade's really good at writing
characters that have no emotion I'm just
saying that his writing style lends
itself to this kind of this kind of
writing but the idea here is that this
this being that appears doesn't really
identify itself doesn't really say you
know what it is
in particular all it really says is that
it's here it's it's there to to
basically help the vision now a lot of
what this thing says is emic mattock and
this is really Markway just setting up
future stories for for Marvel now 2.0
regarding the regarding the Avengers but
it's this idea that this thing says have
you fully thought about every everything
it is that you're going to do now vision
is coming from this or coming to this
from from a calculating standpoint he's
like yes I'm purged of emotion I'm
thinking about this logically I'm
thinking about this reasonably you know
I've considered temporal paradoxes and
this thing says no that's not what I'm
talking about
what I'm talking about as have you
really thought about this on a
fundamental level now again there's no
definitive answer here I can't tell you
exactly what it is that this thing's
referring to because Mark Waid doesn't
tell us he kind of leaves it to us to
infer maybe it's talking about have you
thought about the human side have you
have you thought about how this is going
to impact you in the future when you
recall this memory that you basically
killed an infant but are you basically
crossing a line that you can't come back
from you know and this is this really
seems to be the case because of the fact
that vision says well you know I mean I
recognize that they were going to be
temporal weeks you know there's gonna be
temporal eddies that are going to emerge
because of everything that's happened
you know on the far side of the universe
some rift may open up and start sucking
things through or it may just be that
there'll be changes in the timeline or
something along those lines you know I
thought about that and I recognize that
will happen but this thing says that's
gonna happen either way you know the the
fact that there are temporal you know
anomalies the fact that there are
contradictions in time there are
continuity errors this is just a
byproduct of a person time traveling so
you know because of the fact that that
came to conquer travels through time and
creates these it stands to reason that
there's going to be you know continuity
errors if he doesn't exist like it's
just a byproduct of how the universe
unfolds because of that we don't get a
direct answer in terms of the
conversation between the two all we
really do is just pick up the next
morning and we essentially just have you
know came to conquer his mother going
into his room and when she gets there
you know came to conquer is basically
just gone so the answer is it given to
us in terms of where their vision took
king you know what happened to him or
we ended up going and again this is
really just kind of Mark Waid setting up
for future things but I love this idea
because most of the civil war - tie-ins
really just dealt with you know Ulysses
going to some guy and saying hey that
person over there is gonna do bad things
and that's super hero response it's it's
cookie cutter storytelling with Mark
Waid that's not it's not how this
unfolds it's this deep philosophical
argument of predictive justice you know
is it okay for you to keep someone from
committing a crime if you know they're
going to commit a crime but if just by
virtue of going back in time and
stopping them you've altered the
timeline can you even guarantee they're
going to commit that crime now and so it
creates these these really really cool
you know philosophical questions these
great debates and I'm kind of curious
cuz I'd like to know your all's
responses but and try not to be
knee-jerk I mean try to give us some
thought but if you could go back in time
and you could kill someone like Adolf
Hitler before they rose to power you
know would you do it would you do
something like that you know do you know
that the future would turn out as well
as you think it is you know how do you
think things would be I'm kind of
curious I know a lot of you guys really
dig those those deep thoughts and stuff
like that and some I'm kind of curious
where were you guys come out with that
but um if you guys are new here to
comics explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you on ER
peace
[Music]